hey what's going on everybody uh welcome
to another
uh episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
i am just checking in on you you're
probably wondering
well hey man like it's usually audio
only
why are you sitting here with your sky
blue background because i have a very
special guest
honored to have the amazingly talented
wolfgang van halen on the podcast
what's going on man what's going on
thanks for having me this is uh
this is a trip dude that's you you're
sitting in
arguably probably the coolest room i've
ever seen
it's like it's not enough that you got
drums in the guitars and looks at a
marshall stack you also got the red
lighting there you got blue going on
it's a hell of a setup over there it'll
look really nice and and you decided to
fly into the sky for me and that's
that's great well you know what it was
is i usually use this stupid black
background
that for some reason has these dandruff
marks
on it but then i also wore a black shirt
and we were trying to figure out how to
do it andrew's going open up your shirt
more which
it's weird then i'm like blindingly
white i kind of look like a yin-yang
sign
with my white skin and and the black
shirt so
anyway um i can't tell you what an
honor it is to have you on this podcast
i saw you in 2007
at the staples center and uh
totally kicked out it was just an
amazing show
and um i remember what i remember from
that show was forever i
always i'm a you know drum geek i always
wondered if alex played uh
was it mean streets if he played that
high hat with one hand or two
i got a bunny mind claims the studio
version was one hand i'm like how could
you play it that fast
i'm i'm pretty sure the studio is one
hand like every now and then i think
it's just depending on how his hands
feel
does he do either way but i think on the
on on fair warning it's with one hand
the mystery solved because guess what
dude i went to the bathroom because i
was drinking back then
so i'm in the bathroom stall and i hear
banana
content and i was on this store and i go
oh no
like i was gonna take like a five minute
piss and then some guy who's watching
his hand goes
oh no like mocked me and i felt like an
[ __ ]
so anyway all right so you answered my
drum greek question which i was gonna
save until the end but we are here to
talk about
um your new album that's out that's i'm
sorry not that is is going to be coming
out
uh let me let me just read this thing so
i don't screw up you ban mammoth
okay mammoth uh it's set to release
self-titled debut album on june 11th
day after my birthday uh via uh x1
records
now available for pre-order on found dot
e-e slash mammoth
wvh and um dude i gotta tell you man
the tracks that i heard so far
absolutely killer you have your own
sound it was completely not what i
expected and um
then i was reading the the whole release
on it that you played
all the instruments and sang
every note on it and by the way dude
your voice is ridiculous
thank you especially when you get up
into those higher registered you're
making me a little emotional man you're
you're incredible singer so i got to ask
was
with your parents was there music on
both sides
not really uh it was kind of mostly on
on
my dad's side um that's amazing because
i was sitting there because usually you
know
like if if somebody this is what i
always compare to like michael jordan's
kids
they're like well how come michael
jordan's kids never made it to the nba
it's like well
because he he he's half michael
like it's like drugs that have been
stepped on like he bred with the wife
now instead of being six six two he's
all you know he's only like
five ten five eleven he can't go to his
left
and opposites attract so i figured
jordan maybe married some clumsy woman
and that's what ended up happening
but i was so just blown away with
um um um first of all the
the first one that came out was a
distance yeah
um sorry my i got my [ __ ] all over the
place here uh
worry about it let me don't worry about
it dude
you've been on this podcast for like 20
minutes watching me trying to click
links to songs that i couldn't get to
open
and everybody else could listen to him
and then all of a sudden i was coming up
it's like
do you have a password like what is the
password it's just like how come nobody
else has to give out a password so
i just want to make sure i get the name
of the second song right
uh you're to blame now that's the one
when i first listened to it i thought it
was in an
odd time so yes of the
the phrasing on guitar
and i had to listen to it for half a
second then i just had to snap to the
snare i'm like no
this isn't four um had a
little bit of tool kind of vibe to it um
so how does one person
first of all how the hell did you learn
how to play all of those instruments
that well
thank you um most people
would and most most people immediately
go like oh well he had a good teacher
and uh that's not true my dad was a
terrible teacher
i have a drink i have a great drum
teacher and i suck
i know i know i know dave he's a buddy
oh okay so um how would so how would he
go about
one of the main one of the main things
my dad taught me um
for drums which was the first thing i
learned um was he
he put a couple magazines on a table and
with one he made me do like eighth notes
and the other one do a snare right like
if you do your foot in between the beat
that the snare is doing it
that's playing you can you can play
highway to hell right now
right uh as soon as he realized i could
do it he was like
[ __ ] yes he got me a drum kit
for my birthday um and then i played
uh to van halen best of volume one
and enema of the state by blink 182
until i could figure out how to
how to yeah and i just kind of took it
from there so it's almost like my dad
just gave me a little nudge
with everything but then i kind of
figured everything out as i went along
yeah cause i got two kids now and
uh my daughter actually when she wants
to
she's only like four you know when did
you start
uh nine tennis oh okay good all right
i'm jumping the gun because
that was one of the questions i was
gonna ask you like how do
i expose my kids to music
without forcing my failed rock star
dream on them
and maybe he never forced it on me it
was kind of like
he could see that if i was listening to
a song i could tap to the beat properly
he was like okay he's got it you know
but uh it wasn't until i was nine or ten
okay
so i am jumping the gun because she
wants she's all about her scooter
and her balance bike and i'll be like
hey you want to go in i got a little
soundproof thing in the garage you want
to go in the garage and play drums and
uh
she's just like yeah no i don't i don't
think i want to
so when you're doing all of this stuff
yourself
like like what what is your main
instrument
because you kind of you just rip on
everything i started on drums so i'd
like to
even though i've never played
technically in a band live on the drums
i'd like to think that it's my main
instrument
who are your biggest influences on drums
obviously al you know my uncle uh but
you know everyone but
for like john bonham uh danny barry
uh uh gavin harrison the drummer for
yeah
porcupine tree yeah drummer i went
through a whole
phase with him yeah he's got that cool
setup he's got the three racks and the
two fours
and all the stuff and those cool little
symbol accents he has
just the kind of drummers where it's
like you can't even contain their
awesomeness
on cd like they're even better live
that's gavin harrison for sure
so have you ever written a song where
you came up with like the drum
anything on this album where you just
come up with like a killer groove
and you're like oh man i gotta record
this and then i gotta
like because it always seems like
everything is either starts on piano
or then it or it's it it's it's it goes
or it's a guitar riff
yeah i never hear somebody like oh you
know this guy just was playing a killer
drum beat and i heard a whole song
usually it
for me i'm just like noodling around on
my acoustic guitar
and then it's like oh this is cool and
then i go upstairs and
go on the logic and dial in some sounds
and
come up with like a scratch drum track
and and record a little thing
and then i just kind of listen to that
over and over again until i figure out
where i want it to go
now is that like a thing do you uh when
you come up with something because i
find this with like writing
like i'll write something like a script
and i'll be like dude this is hilarious
i'm gonna sell this this is gonna be the
[ __ ]
and then like i get busy and i come back
and i
read it and it's like somebody else
wrote it and i'm like what is this [ __ ]
i don't even know what the rhythm
because like right as you read it like
it's all fresh in your head the rhythm
of how everything goes
and then it's like somebody gave it to
you like and i can't hear the
the writer's voice anymore and i'm like
this sucks i can't believe it's gonna
send this out to somebody
is writing a song anywhere like that oh
it's
super similar i think uh you know
sometimes you just you have an idea you
like and then you come back to it you're
like wait that that's [ __ ]
terrible uh but i think a big thing is
that like
sometimes if you're writing something
and you get stuck
you can't push it like there are a
handful of times on the album where i
just couldn't figure out
the right lyric for like a chorus or
something
after an hour or two of trying i just
kind of gave up and was like i'll come
back to it later
and more often than not i'd come back to
it and figure it out right away
right or you yeah you're going driving
down the street and you're like oh [ __ ]
you can only
beat your head against the wall for so
long how long did now how that because
that's a very mature
point to get to somebody creating like
how long did it take you to get
when you were younger would you just sit
and like just lose a weekend
trying to come up with two yeah it took
a really long time i mean i
i started writing for this album that's
gonna come out
in june uh when i got off the second van
halen tour i was a part of so
in 2013 so wow
it's like now was that due to like you
know were you busy in your personal life
or
a lot of different things uh you know i
was just it was taking me a while to
figure out who i wanted to be as my own
artist
and then there was the the van halen
tour in 2015
um and then i really slowed down around
16 up until now because of everything
that happened with my dad
right and now what was it like as far as
like uh
because you know the as we all know
anybody who ever
anybody who's been on the internet it's
not the nicest place
it is that's the funniest thing like i
am so sick of them
just building up joe's six-pack it's
like are you reading what joe six-pack
is writing i mean it's someone like they
always like
you know these people in the public eye
really need to be taken down a notch
it's like believe me it's happening
i i got a uh i got a documentary that i
helped produce with all things comedy
uh-huh comedy central and uh von d carlo
about patrice o'neill so
i all i did was just say it was coming
out and like an
[ __ ] i go you know what i'm gonna
check in on the comments
now most of them were positive but you
know those aren't the ones that sticks
with you
and some [ __ ] wrote like uh
i don't know because he watched a
trailer he's like i don't know i feel
like i've already seen this before
you know i hope it goes deeper than uh
you know what what i've already seen
it's like no no we did a superficial one
we tried to make it as cheesy as
possible it's like dude you are already
[ __ ] on it
before you've been seeing it well that's
i get that all the time
i mean just all the time i've been
dealing with that [ __ ] like even
recently
somebody commented on one of the four
second teasers i posted and was like
sounds like everything else it's like oh
wow you can really judge a whole album
by four seconds
hello did you go and name that tune man
you'd win a whole bunch of money
i think but it turns into a game for me
most people
are always like when i interact
with with the [ __ ] people yes
message me and they're like hey man
don't do that that's you know you
when you feed it you know it comes back
to bite in and only comes back stronger
and it's like
i've been here for a while and it has
not gone away
so i'm gonna entertain myself and make
jokes about it and point it out and [ __ ]
like that
like yeah it's it's almost like a puzzle
like i remember a couple years ago
one of my favorite troll moments was
like
uh it was a picture of my dad and i we
were at six flags we were flipping off
the camera
um and it was just maybe it was his
birthday or something
posted and somebody was like yeah except
uh
one is the [ __ ] legend and the other
one's just an okay backup musician
and i quoted it and i said hey
my dad is more than just an okay backup
musician
it's it's like something you've got to
try and figure out how to how to make
make yourself laugh out of it or else
i know do you know how many times i've
started to respond and my fingers
quivering getting ready to hit send i'm
like you know what just walk away
oh there's so many times where i've
posted something wrong like that
may have been a mistake but we'll deal
with that's a problem for future wolfie
yeah well i i think you know i've always
wondered how um people like uh
you know i i watched like like jason
bonham
you know i'm old man so i remember when
he came out
with his band bonham way back in the day
and it was just like
and i remember reading the articles and
he was like into stuart copeland and all
of these guys a lot of these guys that
hit
after his dad had passed and
everyone wanted him they were sort of
trying to steer him into
this thing you know hey just go do
what you know what your dad did it's
like no i am a i am intimately aware
yeah so
like um did you have to
talk to anybody because you you have a
really chill
cool vibe so i like i don't know if you
just naturally like that
like how do you not let um
i mean because you know nobody loves
failure more
than someone who's never achieved
something so
they just are like they're almost like
please [ __ ] this up please [ __ ] this
up i mean i i just i've dealt with it
for so
i mean i mean i i i was
i joined van halen in in 2006.
right so i think that's about 13
plus years of being in in that
limelight of that fun that fun spot yeah
of people hey let's take our day out on
wolf
exactly so at a certain point i just
like i guess the the
calluses builds up and you and you get
ready to kind of like bounce it off and
make a couple jokes about it
um but yeah i mean i i went to therapy
for a couple years and you just kind of
you get the tools you need to kind of
laugh [ __ ] off i mean that's not the
entire reason why
i have fun with comments and stuff but
that was more personal because i've seen
you make a few comments it's like i
think the self-deprecating
we probably shouldn't be like reading
from the playbook here on this
this is how i do it you know what that
reminds me of is people who have guns in
their houses
and then they go on the radio so i you
know what i got a shotgun
right over the [ __ ] kitchen door i
got two blah blah it's like that's great
buddy
to let him know what he needs to bring
and where did he say i don't need to
bring a gun
i just got to get to that shotgun above
the [ __ ] door before he does
um so when you were uh
going through this whole thing there
must have been a point
where you were going like am i ever
gonna get this this damn thing
done yeah i mean there were so many
moments that it was kind of
like i was in my own way like it took me
a really long time to figure out how to
how to write lyrics and that was a big
hold up for me like the music
came pretty quickly um but by the time
it was time to record lyrics it was like
i only had had
a couple songs done that i was really
happy with
and my producer was like we're not ready
like we finished recording
these five songs and we have a bunch
left but it's like
we don't we don't have it yet so right
or and since my producer's schedule is
so busy there are a handful of moments
where it's like
all right i've got time and it's like i
don't have the lyrics yet and it's like
okay i'll see you in a couple months
right and there was you know maybe a
year and a half of that time that kind
of just like
did nothing and then by the way what
would that be like that phelan when he
would say
all right i'll see you in another couple
months he's just like yeah i was just
like
[ __ ] although there was one time where
we were
ready to go and i was gonna fly to him
in orlando and uh hurricane
irma [ __ ] that [ __ ] up for me so it
was
i was finally ready and it was like god
damn it [ __ ]
clouds right is there is now
did you ever during this whole process
like was like seven years for this whole
thing to get going right
yeah uh dude it took me like 20 years to
get through college don't beat yourself
up here
um this was my college that's what i
like hey like
i didn't go to college but i i guess uh
this
i can call this yeah i think you went to
college and then a little bit of law
school
maybe a year of med school with seven
years but like um
is there any was there any time what was
the reason that you decided to do it all
yourself and not go out and audition a
band and
um i wanted to see if i could
uh right and it's funny uh speaking of
shitty comments i got one comment where
it was like
of course he's too selfish to not not
let other people play
and it's like what a weird way to flip
that around
it's like you're just gonna [ __ ] hate
anything aren't you it's just i just
wish i could get to a place where i
could just realize that's
that person's childhood that's not i
mean dude
if i was a fish i would be dead the
first day
the first hook i saw i would and that
would be it i
[ __ ] like nobody takes the bait like me
and um i i progressed off of social
media
to then oh i take breaks i mean as far
as like not calm
i just talk about sports in [ __ ] or
whatever because i mean you can't even
just say something uninformed now
oh no something uninformed now is just
like people
act like something racist happened
well dude i said i was just like no i
just i said something that wasn't right
and i thought it was
when i announced i was going to be on
kimmel [ __ ]
the q anon brigade hit up was like there
was one person who was like oh man i'm
super excited and then other person was
like
man why are people upset about this and
the next comment was all caps
jimmy kimmel's a pedophile it's like
oh yeah uh i don't know what that has to
do with me i'm just
you know trying to promote my my band on
television
pedophile ring by the way i keep moving
up and i just never see
i don't know who the leader is where is
the yeah the mountains of coke and all
of that
what i see is just a bunch of people
working 18-hour days
missing their kids growing up that's the
level of show business that i've always
been in but
you know i guess there's creeps
everywhere but uh you know what's funny
is those same people probably will go to
a go to [ __ ] church and if you're
my church it's just like they they did
that stuff
it's just that i don't know that the
amount of um
the frustrating back and forth of that
uh
i'm trying to learn to let go but um
when this when this album comes out june
11th the day of my birthday which i
think are going to be for you yeah that
was for you
the two i'm going to open for you
perfectly
making another dry ass cake for myself
um no i made a birthday i may always
make sure i make a birthday cake
uh for my daughter and this year i have
a son so i'm gonna make sure every year
that i do that with them and we're just
trying to uh
you know do the right thing so i was a
little sick she brought a cold home so
we all to get tested to make sure it
wasn't covered it wasn't coveted and
then when i went to make a birthday cake
it says keep it in for 30 to 35 minutes
my stove is a little moody like
sometimes it feels like you know some
some nice it wants to play some nights
it doesn't right sometimes it phones it
in
so i was sick so i was just like all
right i'm taking out 32 and a half
minutes i didn't check
and i didn't do a taste test and then
all my relatives came over and they all
ate it and just
these silence i've been into i was just
like this sucks
and everybody's like no every you know
you want people like truck
good that's good but you know when
everybody's voices go up into falsetto
oh it's good yeah it was great it was
just i was just like
i'm gonna go and then i was just like i
am not gonna ruin my daughter's birthday
by pouting that the cake that i made
this is not about you bill
so i didn't say anything and so the next
day i apologized about the cake
everybody said no i don't know what
you're talking about you're too hard on
yourself
you're you're you're over critical it
was fine and then guess what happened
the [ __ ] cake sat there and nobody
else took another slice
[Laughter]
and i just kept eating it because i
didn't want to waste it
this is my shame i would eat it and my
wife would be going what are you
i'm like oh this sucks and she goes so
why are you eating it it's just empty
calories i'm like
toddlers
[Laughter]
so i end up yelling at my wife because i
made a bad kick it's just [ __ ]
it's ridiculous so um so anyway
so now you you made this thing yourself
[ __ ] crushed it but and i saw in the
press release that you're gonna have uh
that you you know you're going to get a
band together obviously go out you're
going to do
um jimmy kimmel when is the jimmy kimmel
and good morning america and the whole
press tour going down um
well if this if this is thursday
then him will first name it it'll be
thursday next week yeah
can then do the future man yeah i think
kimmel will have happened
a week ago uh today i want to compliment
you on crushing it on kimmel
and good morning america is or i'm [ __ ]
the today show the competitor sorry
we're talking about
maybe we can edit that uh it's all right
it's all right do you ever have you ever
done one of those morning shows
not like i i did i did the today show
when distance came out and i talked to
carson daly did you have to sing on it
no i was not nowhere near ready it took
me forever to figure out how to
get ready to sing because i've noticed
like i've done you know i used to do the
old p
anthony show and they would have these
amazing musicians come in
and they would always be like going like
[ __ ] man i got to sing at eight in the
morning
i think covet has been uh is ironically
in terms of
my nervousness uh a lifesaver because
uh i'm not in the studio like ready to
do it it's all
zoom and stuff right and uh it would
sound really shitty what sort of like
before you
were to go do a show what sort of nerves
oh it's
just like my dad my dad had crazy nerves
that's why he would drink
you know isn't that funny though like
the best guys i think the reason why
they're the best is because they still
think that they're not good
oh yeah that's very true so he was so he
his routine was he he'd have a couple of
pops what would you do
ah just be really nervous and deal with
it somehow
all right what was it like the first
night
you got you got to step in for michael
anthony charlotte north carolina
in 2007. um you sound like a vietnam vet
da nang 68 number i think
all right so you're sitting backstage
and you're just like
i mean obviously you rehearsed the songs
a million times
when when it came to to al dad and i we
we rehearsed everything to death like it
became boring
and i enjoyed that because i could focus
on another level
on top of every like it was all
automatic at that point right
now when you say you you guys rehearsed
like until it was like how long did you
rehearse how many hours a day how many
days a week how does that go down
get together every day monday through
friday maybe even saturday
um couple hours five or five hours a day
maybe
just run through the set list twice or
three times
so you basically are playing the concert
oh yeah nice
holy [ __ ] and how long did you do that
before you when you started feeling like
you were locking in you were settled you
were settling yeah you felt like
i'm a part of this rather than well the
very first photo
was that was kind of in 2005 before
there was ever even
any plans like al and dad were just in
the studio
jamming and i picked up a base one time
and then we started jamming and it was
like oh this is kind of fun and then i
went home
and i made a list it's still hanging up
at the studio uh
i made a van van halen trio jams
list with hagar songs roth songs just
whatever just different van halen songs
anything outside of the uh the van halen
world just
it was just vh songs and uh
we just i came back i learned them that
night came back and we just
started playing them and it was maybe a
month or two or a couple months or
something where we realized like
hey this is pretty [ __ ] cool uh
and then i we all know but i'm confused
were you
from the beginning in the band or you
just started jamming and that's okay
we're coming for fun you know
uh because at that point you know i i
don't know
all the the details on dude i gotta be
honest with you i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i love everybody that's been in
that band and i just want everybody to
get home
mike is a great [ __ ] guy and i can't
tell you what happened between
my dad and him all i can say is that
it's like
he was kind of over here and my dad was
kind of over here and honestly i don't
blame him because my dad was he was
going through a really rough time
during those times so i could understand
why mike did right
and i guess dad took that as well okay
[ __ ] you i'll
i'll just be jamming with my son over
here then and that's when he got sober
and and then it was kind of like
me being around was that thing that kept
him to be not as nervous
right that's something man i never he
because he had such a relaxed
because it was all those guys like i i
always felt like
uh that your dad was so misunderstood
as a player like my general like i came
uh
what was van halen uh 78 so when i
really started becoming like aware
of you know once i got out of the
records my parents bought me like sing
along with mitch miller in the gang and
lawrence welk winchester cathedral uh
once i got out of that i think i had
like aerosmith's greatest hits was the
first one because i heard walked this
way and i thought it was the coolest
song because
he was singing so fast or at least what
was considered fast back then
um then i got into all metal and that
type of stuff
and like looking back like i just felt
they misinterpret like you're because
they didn't have his talent
they just sort of interpreted as
here's a solo play as many notes as you
possibly can
and just like uh you know an ad but
nobody was like
saying anything there's a little bit of
that i feel like when i watch
um a lot of drum videos now
like these kids can blaze can
blaze but every time they're playing a
groove and it sounds great and then they
go to do
like a fill everything sounds like
30-second notes
and it's just like oh can i show off in
in this one
area all right everybody we gotta read a
sponsor here
all right everybody it's roman you know
talking about
erectile dysfunction isn't easy
usually we just brush it off hey you
know whatever had too much whiskey
or blame ourselves saying things like i
just lost my
my mojo you know i had uh
too much cognac um or we avoid it all
together with
excuses like i had a long day at work or
sorry honey i'm just not
feeling it well wait why can't you say
that maybe that's true
not allowed to have a long day at work
you know
it's not like you're a woman you just
lay there i mean we got to go to work
here
it's like a second job sorry um but with
roman
it's easy to talk about with a real
health care professional who can
prescribe
real medication it's simple safe
and totally discreet yeah dude if your
dick isn't working you just got to go in
you got to look them right in the eye oh
actually on this you don't right you can
call them up
uh with roman you can get a free online
evaluation
evaluation and ongoing care for
erectile dysfunction all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
uh healthcare professional will work
with you uh to find the best treatment
plan if
medicine is appropriate roman will ship
it to you
with free two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward
simple and discreet getting started is
simple just go to roman.com
slash bur and complete an online visit
erectile dysfunction
used to be tough to tackle well yeah i
mean it's easy to tackle but standing up
straight
get your arms around it um if
if approved sorry i'm immature go [ __ ]
yourself if approved
you'll get 15 off your first order of ed
treatment that's get roman.com
get roman r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
b-u-r-r there's one guy too because
there's one there's one
that i follow where they're just always
read it's sort of like this hub
of awesome young drummers you know men
women every from
around the planet there's just some
incredible players and there's just one
dude i don't know what the deal is
they post him like every single day and
he does like this ridiculous
independent polyrhythmic [ __ ]
but it all it's just always like one two
one two three four that's right
it just sounds like you remember that
steve carell thing where
liar liar and jim carrey was making him
talk oh yeah
like you could literally put him doing
that
over the drum solo and it would it would
be it would match
yeah yeah so um
i was one it did did uh
what i liked about the songs that i
heard
was the air and the space in it
um you know it's just like
is is that something that just like like
you said you said you said that your dad
wasn't a good teacher which is kind of
funny to me
yeah well it's just like einstein you
know how they
now you know like einstein couldn't tie
his own shoes and [ __ ] like he was right
for his own good right dad would just be
like
do this and i'd be like [ __ ] you
i can't do that you're eddie van halen
could you do it slower
he proceeds to be eddie van halen in
front of me when i ask him how to how to
play something it's like okay well
there's a big line between beginner
twelve-year-old wolfie asking how to
play something and [ __ ] eddie van
gaal
so at what age were you when you were
kind of like hey my dad's kind of good
at guitar
walking around the house and like he's
just failing
scrolling i i never really realized a
moment because i had been
you know my my mom took me to shows
since i was like three there are videos
of me like running up on stage
just this random three-year-old probably
pissing off the audience going who the
[ __ ] is this kid
i want to see more guitar you know but
uh
well what are they this is a dumb this
is not a dumb question but what do they
do for
uh hearing protection because i i that
this ear here
all kids got the like the big like cans
where you just can't yeah the leaf
blower yeah exactly
thanks oh all right that's interesting
all right can i ask one more uh
alex drum geek question i'm gonna try to
slip in as many as i possibly can
of course go um
all right did he play ludwig and pisces
symbols
because he was into bonham even though
he didn't sound like him he had his own
sound or
because i know he started playing before
um i mean where they started they pretty
much started when they were kids in the
late 50s early 60s they started playing
together so that was zeppelin didn't
come out till 68.
and i know that ludwig was the cadillac
of drums
but it was sort of zildjian it seemed
like european guys
would get the piesty stuff and american
drummers would have the zildjian stuff
and when he came out i remember looking
at his drum kit
thinking he was gonna be a bottom guy
and then he sounded
nothing like him yeah
which i thought was a major a major
accomplishment
absolutely footprint
you know oh i think i think he's one of
the most underrated drummers of all time
it's just simply because everyone was so
watching your dad yeah it's like just
look over here for a second you'll see
how [ __ ] great
you see how amazing he is yeah even like
the simple stuff
like simpler songs the creativity that
he had in it the uh
uh finish what you started all sort of
that offbeat stuff and every time
whenever i try to air drum to it i
always think it's going to be snare and
then it's his kick
and then i then i lose where one is and
then he comes out and it's just like
uh or even like that like a pop song
like jump like his like
when they're going in the course like
his like symbols and like the
fills that he does and that bell thing
like i was trying to my arms are getting
crossed up like how the hell does he do
this that tongue is tricky like you
think jump
you think of jumping it's like oh simple
pop song but it's got some some left
turns in it for sure and then that
little double bass lick
towards the end which i've never been
able to figure that out
[Laughter]
all right last one hot for teacher does
he play that
intro with his feet or was that with
floor toms i'm pretty sure it's floor
toms because it was
you know it's the uh what is it the roto
toms or whatever right electric
okay or they were like electric uh toms
that he played on 1984.
and i think at least the way i would
always do it is and i think it's a clear
indicator when you're listening to it
because he kind of starts off with his
hands doing the
oh yeah dude and that phil he does in
where he goes up the tongue
oh my god dude that makes my hair stand
up on my
to this day
my big success today is i drove my
daughter to school
today and she said 38 special and
she goes ac dc what does that mean
because she thinks it spells something
and then she goes dad because i was
playing back in black yeah
she's going uh she said something these
guys this music
is crazy because you know brian is like
screaming he's screaming yeah yes and i
was like oh is this scary go but do you
like it and she goes yeah
so i'm like all right this is really
cool because my wife is
like she grew up on like you know
hip-hop and new jack swing and all that
janet jackson stuff so i feel like when
she goes to school it's like two
different
completely different djs or whatever
that's funny
yeah it was my dad and ice band we we
bonded over
over power rich big time i was like i
know
it seems like every musician like that's
their
that's their favorite one i gotta think
what is my favorite ac i i it kind of
changes um
like you know what my big thing is over
the last few years you know i think the
power rage album
is of the brian johnson era i used to
say flick of the switch
but now i actually think uh for those
about to rock
is one of my favorite sounding oh
and phil rudd on cod oh yeah
is just like in in insane so
all right so i saw this thing like i'm i
sort of like
mainly play drums but i mess around on
guitar so something easy like 38 special
hold on loosely and i i saw the guitars
talking about
how he was listening to um
that car song was i don't mind you
standing here
so the guitar is all like eighth notes
so he was playing around with that
and then came up with that down on that
and then he just sort of
yeah now that's an approach
and then i hear other people like oh i
just woke up and i just heard this thing
is songwriting because i i wouldn't like
if you told me
like you're you're going to jail unless
you can write a song like i just well i
i just give me you know
yeah yeah for sure if you put a gun to
my head it'd be like well give me a
second i had to go through these
ideas i have on on my voice memos and
maybe that this one will be good i don't
know
but there's a funny thing there's the
third song on the album i think
is called epiphany and that was the demo
title because it came out of nowhere
and it the title just kind of stuck
so do you do you um
you just noodle around and or you'll
you'll like like hear something you're
watching the tv you got an acoustic
guitar or something and then something
hits and you're like oh [ __ ] you pull
your phone out so you're absent lying to
me playing and then something like catch
that's
that's amazing man i i i feel like
musicians and songwriting it's like
wizardry like doing what i do you see
somebody do something stupid and they go
you know we see these guys dude what the
[ __ ] up with that it's pretty it's
pretty basic and not too much we're
hiding behind like instruments and [ __ ]
you gotta stand up there and [ __ ]
just womb with words that's terrifying
uh i'm not lie to you it is
it is but it is not as terrifying as a
few other things
there's a few there's some other things
that i've done that are a little scarier
than that um but
i don't know i don't want to toot my own
horn but i i got a pilot's license and
the other day i finally soloed this
helicopter and you got it you got to set
it
i had to set it down on a helipad which
looks
gigantic when you're looking at it but
then when you're coming into it and
there's like a four-wheeler attached to
it
and all you're thinking is don't hit the
four-wheeler don't hit the four-wheeler
well don't think about hitting the
formula because i need to hit it like
that type of [ __ ]
um and it's it's like through doing
stand-up
and having to be like that's david
letterman over there and i'm gonna
completely ignore that
so i can focus and not forget my act
and um you learn like those compart
compartments i don't know how to say you
compartmentalize
stuff um i'm kind of into uh
like people having breakthroughs because
i'm really trying to because
like i'll be honest with you dude like
that that video you had you know
with your dad and everything i was like
jesus christ he was an even better dad
than he was a guitarist
and it's like like i want to be like
that
so when you were having the problems
with um
like coming up with like lyrics and
stuff
i i would i would have to think like
that's like
where i can i can hide behind comedy
being hey i'm the guy i don't know you
know me i don't give a [ __ ] you know so
i don't
keep everybody like that how like you
guys really like i
couldn't imagine being in a band
and they they they come in with the riff
and you're the lead singer or whatever
and you get and it's and it's sounding
like a love song
and then you got to go up to the mic and
start singing about some chick you love
and you're g
and like i would be afraid to look at
anybody they'd be like the [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ]
oh yeah i thought you were going to sing
about heroin what are you the hell are
you talking about
well that's the first time i've ever
really felt like this because with van
halen you know
i'm just in the background playing bass
but
but with this it's like this is my life
and and my heart
i i put into into this and so it's like
when people go like this [ __ ] sucks
it's like
that hurts a little bit more than than
than it did before
because you're saying yeah but you know
you deal with it dude it's a killer
record man [ __ ] those people i swear to
god and then you know what the reality
is
is you really do the math it's not
that many people that do that [ __ ]
that's
what i could always say you know because
there were so many people at least early
on that were convinced
i wasn't even playing and it was just
like my dad put me up there and it was
all the
thing and at first that hurt but then
eventually it was like wait a second so
what did they think did they think
michael anthony was sitting in the
corner on punishment
backstage whatever fits their their
agenda
but i took it as a compliment eventually
because that means
it sounds so good that they can't
imagine that it's not tracks
so but he would always say he's like
listen wolf whenever
whenever the album comes out if if those
[ __ ] people don't get it
they never will and uh right
that always stuck with me where it's
like this is like fully me
so it's like i i if i've been if i
if i've been coasting on a lie these
last 13 years i don't think i can hide
it for much longer yeah
so um
what was something else i want to ask
okay so let's talk bass players
okay so who influenced you like
who's like your top bass player
uh as far as like justin chancellor
from tool is oh wow
um him and les claypool are are probably
they're
super different bass players right but
then you got you know like tony levin
you know he plays with he's oh and so
many people but i
i don't i don't know tony 11 i'm an old
guy who is that you're gabriel
um oh okay i should have known that one
he's a [ __ ]
incredible bass player um and uh he's
done so
just look him up so many can you just
figure [ __ ] out because i always have to
go on like youtube
and watch somebody turn stuff by ear
yeah
i should have done that because i feel
like you're just like illiterate
if you go the uh the other way all right
well right we we've uh we've talked
about music a lot here so what what
what are your uh what are any other
interests you have are you a sports guy
did you watch the super bowl
did you predict tampa bay like me i
i i did not i'm not my mom would be the
one to talk to about that because she's
a [ __ ]
rabid saints fan and oh she she's from
new orleans
no she isn't she she she lived in
shreveport
and since they were technically in
louisiana
she began to root for the saints because
everybody root for the cowboys there
uh so my uncle patrick and her would
then
then became die hard saints fans and
what year did they become die hard
oh man i don't know a long time ago 70.
so she
that's legit yeah because once drew
brees got there and
she's legit way before drew brees so
what uh
how nuts did she go when they won in
2009.
when that dude picked it off picked six
took it to the house
he's uh growing up growing up i hated
football because
every sunday it would be the loudest day
in the house because my mom
is a very good person
hilarious you're so [ __ ] loud dude
it's
it's crazy and was your dad into
football at all no no he didn't give a
[ __ ] he was just kind of like yeah cool
like she's over there screaming at the
tv
oh yeah oh yeah past interference he
does that he's over there
you know working on the next eruption
yeah she can do that that like under the
tongue finger whistle thing that'll
[ __ ] kill you man
oh yeah you know when you get a couple
of kids you learn how to whistle as a
dad
because at some point you just gotta
knock it off
you just it's the only thing you gotta
have like that
you got to have the debt my my dad had a
snap
was the loudest thing dude it was like
there was reverb
yeah up to this thing because it was
also
we would go to church every sunday and
inevitably we would either start [ __ ]
around or
or or get into a fight or something and
we were always thinking that we were
keeping the decibel level low enough
where he didn't hear it
and then at one point he would just be
sitting there like this and then he
would just stick his hand out and just
bash right and then we were all just
like and we're like oh [ __ ]
this car ride home is gonna suck
um all right well let me let me make
sure
that i did the whole uh the whole the
proper promo
of this yes sir june 11th right
uh that's not the [ __ ] thing i wanted
andrew when am i just going to learn to
print things out
instead of having all these windows and
there's something you can do you swipe
with your thumb and then all of a sudden
it all comes back oh there we go
um this is another thing too about it
like there's 13
tracks on this thing at any point when
you were doing this album when you got
like seven years in were you
just like is this my chinese democracy
like am i going insane in here should
should i just
that joke i i i heard that
chinese democracy many rights
um but it's ari
yeah there i recorded way more ideas
that weren't
100 finished for it so it was really
tough to figure out what it
what i wanted on on that album mm-hmm
but
uh after dude i made like
a hundred playlists my uncle patrick and
i were like listening for the flow and
like
each song that went into each other and
it took us forever but we finally
reached
the current album as it is and i'm
really i don't think i've ever worked
that hard on anything i have a thing
where i just like
my shift i'm a micro manager i i go nuts
over
like i am a perfectionist with this
because it's the
hardest i've worked on it worked on
anything do you think
um your next one will come quicker or be
quicker
yeah yeah because i now the next one do
you think
uh like say you go out on tour right
say this co-vid thing ends right and we
can all leave the house
you go out on tour um i mean you're
opening
remember oh is that right i'll open for
you
i'll stay that's one of the worst gigs
ever it's one of the worst gigs ever for
me opening for a band oh yeah it's like
we came here to boom music before the
guy we wanted to see
right now some do talk yeah well
the thing the thing that will save me is
if um
if it's in a smaller club like i
um i used to open for winona judd
and she played big places and you know
every night it was just like
some nights it went good and then other
nights
you know i mean i was joking but if
you're serious let's let's do it man
if you if look if you want to do like uh
like hey let's just do one
live show before we go out then or like
before i
i would absolutely let's do it yeah
i'm gonna go up there dressed like one
of those old you know like the local djs
who used to who would like pump up like
they would pump the single
yeah get out there boston you ready to
run
guys you heard him on bcn yeah
i opened for uh let's see why i don't
own a judd
and then one time i opened for queens of
the stone age but it was at a small
club so it was really cool
that's awesome and it was and they were
nice josh and the guys were nice
enough to keep it lit so when people
[ __ ] on me
you know the whole game is you hit you
have to you have to like
you ever see like those hornets go into
like like nest or like honeybees and
they just they got their things and they
just chop heads off
you have to do that in that gig it's
like you just there's three people
and there three people give you [ __ ]
there has to be three heads on the floor
within two seconds of each or else the
whole thing is just gonna turn and
everybody's going to take their day out
on you
so fortunately i went in there there was
just one chick
you know just running a yap and those
are the hardest ones
good-looking chicks good-looking white
chicks there's there's
there's it's kryptonite there's no way
to shut them up no one has ever told
them to shut up in their life
don't say something that'll piss them
off what's that
you'll inevitably say something that'll
piss them off
i don't think they even they're just so
drunk that they don't they just want to
hear their own voice
well if i go like literally like will
you shut the [ __ ] up you're ruining the
whole show
and then the crowd cheers they think the
applause is for them
like that's that's how pretty they are
it's like they with them applause must
be for me
yeah they can't i am so good-looking i
can't hear criticism
and it's just like i i kind of dealt
with that you know what's so funny is
when someone really [ __ ] annoys me i
i i never quite forget what they look
like
like i just have like you know you know
i can get this zoom chat there's these
zoom faces
oh they have like there's a half dozen
there was this [ __ ] [ __ ] when i
was in um the old punch line
in uh in atlanta
it's [ __ ] jerk off it was one of
these deals where the stage was only
like six
inches high and he came down he was
sitting in the front row
he's one of these guys like he was like
i don't know probably my age now but i
was like in my late 30s
and he still had a button down you know
really tight and he had like the
you know the dad bought but he's still
showing off the gun still lifted so
and uh and he had these stupid penny
loafers with no socks and he had his
feet on the stage with his legs crossed
just sitting there
yeah i felt like i was performing at his
birthday party in his backyard so i
asked him like hey man can you take your
feet off the stage
he's like he's not doing he just
wouldn't do it so i kept [ __ ] on him
and it just kept escalating and
escalating and i'm
you know i'm a pretty angry guy but back
then i was i was a lunatic
and it escalated to the point that
uh he ended up getting kicked out i
remember when he got kicked out
he stood up really deliberately and like
sort of made a half a step towards me
and then went up on the stage and when
that was his last little passive
aggressive thing and i was standing
there
i usually lean on the mic stand i
actually was standing with mike and i
had the mic stand like this
you know mike's got a nice base on it oh
yeah yeah i probably would have blown
out my rotator cuff but i i was gonna
[ __ ]
i already had it worked out it was like
i am going i'm gonna go mid body
because i don't want to get sued i'm
just
there's anything his finger out in some
portion of his body yeah this thing is
metal this is not
wherever i hit him he's going down he's
too [ __ ] old
and um and every once in a while like
when i think
the exact club is no longer there uh
i guess i don't give a [ __ ] about it
anymore i've let go of a lot of stuff
i'm kind of happy with that
yeah you learned to laugh at it i
remember uh
in san jose i think it was the either
2012 or 2015 tour
um and uh the entirety of the show
it was kind of a lower stage it was kind
of like if you've ever been to red rocks
in colorado yeah age kind of or like
hollywood bowl you know because we
played
sheds on the last time i bombed there
i was doing the comedy works and they
tried to bring that up they brought
comics out there did like we went on
after some animation video and then
there was a band and it was just
was not what i wanted it to be sorry
anyway
um and uh some guy throughout the
entirety of the show
he was in like in the sixth row like eye
line with me was flipping me off
just like the whole the whole [ __ ]
time
and in between every break uh i would go
to my tech and be like hey there's a
guy flipping me off and it's really
distracting and he's really rude uh
and i just wanted to tell you that and
he was like just ignore it you know and
then the next break out
i started thinking because like i don't
ever want to be a dick
you know i i like to be a nice person no
wait wait wait wait
how would you be the dick in that
situation that i mean how long is this
that's the way my brain operates is that
i didn't want to
want people to think i was a dick for
trying to like throw somebody out or
something
but oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
not the whole time so
i after the second or third break
i went to my my tech and the security
guard was there i was like
hey is it okay to throw somebody out if
they've been flipping me off the
entirety of the show and they're like
[ __ ] yeah where is he
i was like oh uh he's in the sixth row
he's wearing a dream
dream theater shirt he's balding
i can i can see it i can see it sticking
out like a sore thumb oh absolutely
and the second two security guards start
walking down the aisles you see him like
wow and they didn't find him the first
time we have no idea where he is i was
like he's got the gold chain he's in
like this how many people are wearing a
[ __ ] dream theater t-shirt i've never
seen one in my life
and uh yeah and then they eventually
found him and uh i think he was around
near the end of the show like an ice
cream man or something and
as they're taking him out he turns
around one last look and
i was on the side of the stage and he
turned around i was just like
enjoy the parking lot [ __ ] great it
was it was worth it
what's the worst is that the worst
heckler or whatever that you know it's
one of the worst there are other scarier
ones where like a handful of times
people would shine a uh
a laser pointer at me and you don't know
what the [ __ ] that is
so that that shit's really scary but can
i tell you something that takes me back
to this [ __ ]
this this [ __ ] hero of joe six-pack
that the only way to be the [ __ ] is
if you're the guy
on stage exactly and you're sitting
there going like hey man you know
kind of a guy flipping me up it's a
little distracting i mean you're sitting
there trying to give people a show
this is work i don't come to the [ __ ]
burger king and knock the dicks out of
your mouth
yep
that's like a classic uh stand-up
comeback
i think you i think you'd have to say uh
a gay bath house
because now you now you might get sued
by burger kings like we're not sucking
dicks down here
we're making burgers and they're flame
broiled and they're better than
mcdonald's
um yeah people
you know you don't know if that's a gun
like i hope not but it's like there's
been
people killed on stage before and i
think there are enough van halen fans
that might be crazy enough to hate me so
much that they want to kill me i'm
terrified of that [ __ ]
you know right but it's my job so i
gotta go up there anyway and just hope
it doesn't happen
and when people shine i imagine doing
that to somebody
in your situation and then also
your dad is right there well
there's a lot of people that don't think
through you know they're huge fans of my
dad they idolize him and they
and then the next minute they go tell
his son who is dealing with the loss of
his parent
that he's a piece of [ __ ] and it's like
there's a weird
lapse of judgment in that whole process
that i don't understand
no i've seen like like uh
musicians sons of musicians who are
great players
and it's just like yeah hanging up
you're not as good as your dad it's just
like
what do you mean you mean his dad who's
dead that guy that's that's the guy like
what
in what world it's really is like the
the internet's a really fascinating
place
where uh you kind of see that
a lot of people just never grow up like
you know when you're a little kid and
someone's just like i don't like your
face you know just you just don't know
not to be that rude
that's the internet for sure yeah i feel
like they go back to like
um outdoor recess when you were like in
first second third grade when you were
really at your meanest
yeah when you didn't understand words
effect but you knew enough of the
english language to really go for it
um i'm just i don't know i think because
it's a combination of where the
narrative is and then it's also
uh money
so i feel like and and corporations have
really given
the you know a handful of [ __ ] all
of this power that i didn't like that
and that offended me it's
you know for some reason they can't just
be happy making
999 million dollars they got to get that
one more dollar to make a billion so
it's like all right we're just gonna
flush
exactly this freaking artist so all
right lastly here before we
um before we wind down first of all i
want to say
it's so great to meet you pleasure
i i i really love what i've heard so far
the album
is like i mean that's for people
listening how i
ended up um
getting in touch with you was i heard i
heard that um oh god my [ __ ] memory
dude
what was the second song that i heard
that i i didn't know if it was in your
favor
you're to blame right yeah you're the
blame i heard that i was like what the
[ __ ] made me want to go play drums
okay so that's it also made me fantasize
that's another big thing with me
when i drive down the street i listen to
music whatever the coolest instrument
of singing i am in i am that person
doing it in front of everybody i know
and they're all like wow we didn't know
you had this talent it's embarrassing
but that's what i do
so i somewhere i i've reached out to you
and just said dude
that sounds killer and that's like this
really came
like this was not like a uh hey you got
this amount of followers will you
interview this guy i am
a legit fan so i am hoping
to see you in your band live i hope this
this album gets what it deserves and
um the last thing i wanted to ask you
how optimistic
i'm making everybody be a covid
weatherman here
how optimistic are you that maybe
towards the end of the year
enough people get the vaccine that it
works
i would really hope so man and inject me
with those nanobots
you know i i i'm going in too dude give
me
let bill gates know where the [ __ ] i am
i want to get out there
well i'm due to get it in uh march
so if you notice a little change in my
podcast
you're a youngster so you're probably
not going to get it till may or june but
just use me as a lab rat
you got it i don't see any like i don't
know if i you know what
if i seem at peace with the world then
you should get nervous but if i'm still
going off on people's okay we knew i'm
not
i think all right dude hey man i'm so
psyched i'm proud of you that you got
this thing done
and i really hope the world opens up so
you can go out kick ass
and uh play some live shows because i
think i'm speaking for a lot of people
one of the biggest things
i have missed during this has been live
music so thank god
for unbelievably talented musicians like
yourself good luck with your record
and once again i really enjoyed your
appearance on jimmy kimmel
last week thank you very much all right
wolf
nice meeting you pleasure
[Music]
i could walk away from
this i could replace you
we could
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
february 18th 2013
and uh right off the bat you should be
going like well this sounds a lot
different than all the other ones
yes it does there's a reason for that
the reason for it is because the
handy recorder h4nr by zoom
the zoom h4n
handy recorder is a [ __ ]
diva hunk of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that recorder in its non-existent
digital ass
i've had more goddamn [ __ ] problems
with this thing
first of all they give you a [ __ ]
memory card we can record like just over
a podcast or every
[ __ ] goddamn week i start the podcast
if i forgot to erase the last one
i have a problem and i know what you
guys are thinking well bill why don't
you buy a new [ __ ] memory card
well i'm an [ __ ] okay admittedly i'm
an
[ __ ] but you know what i did you know
what i did people guess where all
[ __ ] billy redface went the other day
well i went to the wrong place first but
then they told me where to go and then i
went i bought a [ __ ] memory card some
60 [ __ ] four gig memory card
i stick it in this thing's [ __ ]
little slot there
turn it on it says uh do you want to
format the card
why yes i would handy [ __ ]
recorder h4n zoom douche right
how childish is this right now trying
not to be mad
inanimate object as joe derosa says
um but i am so i put it in there and it
says
error can't do it then i go on the
internet wasting more [ __ ] time in my
life
are you technology douchebags out there
who just think that this stuff makes
your life easier
it doesn't it doesn't because it's
constantly [ __ ] breaking down
and then i got to go on the internet and
i got to try and figure out
what the hell's going on you know
sifting through all this this horse [ __ ]
and i found something and i followed it
to the t and it still says it's it's
that there's a problem
so what do i have to do i'm in new york
city right now by the way i'm gonna have
to somehow
get in touch with bobby kelly
and i'm gonna flip the [ __ ] out
screaming about tech this is what
happens this is how bobby kelly helps me
with technology i call him up
i immediately go on a rant about
technology and the banking system
he sits back and relaxes you know
probably has the phone like 20 feet from
his ear
and when i'm done ranting you know
he'll just sit there and be like alright
dude what's the problem dude but what do
you what do you have
and i'm like this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
some [ __ ] if it did
dude it's not a piece of [ __ ] dude it's
actually i've had that thing
it's [ __ ] great i got the new one
it's [ __ ] wireless
um and then he talks me [ __ ] through
it
you know and what kills me is i like to
think that i'm just as smart as robert
kelly but evidently i'm not
he never comes to me for help but i
think that's because he's he's afraid
he's afraid of the feelings that he has
for me
[Laughter]
so anyways i don't even know how to
adjust these levels i hope i'm not
blowing out your [ __ ] eardrums here
um anyways you know what was funny about
all this
was i was going to make fun of this kid
who was having problems downloading my
special
you know this is basically you know
fortunately i've had a nice steady
stream
of people downloading my special and uh
i swear to god for every like 50
75 people that downloaded successfully
there'll be one person that has a
problem
i get right back to him you know
usually that day if not within two to
three days i get back to him as soon as
i can we get him a new link
and they get the special all right
and i've actually learned a lot about
myself reading some of these emails
because the amount of people who
immediately assume
that they're getting [ __ ] that
basically that i'm [ __ ] them over
which
you know like i i basic i announced that
i have this special to download for five
dollars and once i get your five dollars
my game plan is there really is no link
like how long could i realistically get
away with that
maybe for a week before all you guys
talk to each other and just like there's
no link he's just stealing five dollars
from us
at which point i would become the
biggest douche on the internet
and no one would come to my shows and i
would go back to sleeping on a futon so
why would i do that but what cracks me
up is i understand the anger
as you can tell i'm sure there's
somebody out there who has a zoom
h4n handy recorder and knows exactly you
know what two [ __ ] buttons to hit
and my whole world would be perfect
um i have to tell you it is an
unbelievably confusing [ __ ] device
this is definitely this has to be some
pro level [ __ ] because they did not dumb
it down for someone like myself
so anyways getting back to the um
getting back to the uh the downloads
okay if you are having problems okay
the link does work okay admittedly a
couple times there has been a glitch on
our end
and we go out we fix it immediately you
will get a link
i am not trying to [ __ ] you over if you
first if you are just like well it
didn't work the first time and i don't
feel like waiting i want my five dollars
back i will um
i will absolutely refund your money
you're not gonna get [ __ ]
okay you're not gonna get [ __ ] out of
your money you're gonna get the special
you're gonna get your five dollars back
so
um i don't know but i've actually
learned a lot about myself watching
people having meltdowns about these
things
this one kid wrote me today he goes i
would like my money back for my purchase
of your special
on january 25th 2013. i never had a
chance to see the special
and i am deeply outraged by the horrible
quality of your customer service
please return my five dollars to my
checking account immediately
so my jesus christ did i miss this guy
so i look up his email
it's [ __ ] hilarious i've already
talked to the guy three times
he got the initial link and we sent him
two more links and he hasn't been able
to download it
okay i got back to him every time either
that day or within 24 hours
and now he asked for his five dollars
back and i gave it back to him within
like
45 minutes of him asking for all right
i understand you're upset dude but how
is that horrible
customer service now if you want to say
it's a horrible link
you know that's one thing my customer
service i'm gonna pat myself on the back
here i think it's pretty [ __ ] good
i wouldn't say it's outstanding all
right i'm not trying to get trashed by
other [ __ ] who are now going to send me
emails
i'm just saying all right sometimes it
does take me like three days to get back
to you but you know
i'm running a mom-and-pop operation here
i gotta fly to [ __ ] uh east bum [ __ ]
to do a show you know that day maybe i'm
not looking at my emails but i will get
back to you
all right and there's been a whole
there's been thousands of people thank
god who downloaded my special
successfully so the link is
fine all right i sent the guy a letter
back i told him i said dude we got back
to you
every time you've emailed us and i just
gave you five dollars back how is that
horrible customer service
i don't know what to tell you what what
more am i supposed to do
fly to where you live and stare at your
computer with you god knows i can't
figure it out
this guy's deeply outraged over five
dollars thank god my special wasn't 20
bucks like i wasn't selling like a hard
copy of it this guy probably hunt me
down and shoot me
oh speaking of shooting people
how about that [ __ ] cyborg huh
allegedly shot his woman through the
[ __ ] bathroom door
jesus christ huh what a [ __ ] creepy
story that is
you know what's funny as i was sitting
here today flipping out
about the zoom h4 this is like the
anti-commercial for this thing
h4n recorder if you're stupid please do
not buy this thing
because you'll end up like me and i'm
really trying to uh
derozan used to have this joke about him
flipping out
at a laptop and somebody saw him and
said hey that's an inanimate object
you're better than that but so i
i for some reason last night i was
flipping about flipping out about
how my internet sucks in new york and
how
because i was so mad at the internet
connection i actually had the urge to
grab my
laptop a completely innocent bystander
and just [ __ ] like sort of like a
combination of a frisbee and a discus
and i wanted to throw it through my
window
[Music]
rather than using my brain and sitting
down
or maybe just solving the problem maybe
just calling up and canceling the
wireless service and getting that little
[ __ ]
uh what do you call it the internet
stogie that you can stick into the side
of your computer
so you have internet everywhere that
bobby kelly [ __ ] did
i get internet everywhere i i stick the
stick in
i put on my little earpiece dude it's
all [ __ ] wireless
it orders me a sandwich you know
um anyways
the [ __ ] was i talking about you know
that guy actually i i made
i made a bad move the other day i asked
i called bobby kelly up and i told him i
needed a new printer
and you can someone like me cannot talk
to a guy like
on bobby kelly's level of technology
okay because
all of my [ __ ] is from like you know
three presidents ago all right i don't
like
technology um as far as i don't like new
technology
okay i would be happy
i was happy with my life was in the 80s
and i didn't have a laptop or a cell
phone i was fine
i don't know about you guys but i was
eating three times a day i had a roof
over my head
you know i had a carburetor
i had no fuel injection and i i was fine
my car couldn't talk to me i didn't have
any gps
i oh i had a map it's not like an old
man here but my life was fine
when i say i don't like technologies for
all the douchebags already firing off
your email
really would you like to go back to the
caveman days
you know what i'm saying past a certain
point this [ __ ] hasn't been helping me
okay right up to curing polio and
penicillin right there we should we
should just walked away from the
blackjack table
we should have left it that you know
then all we would have had to have done
is just
dealt with the population problem in
that you just keep it in check
okay you get one of these mathematical
[ __ ] nerds god bless them
and we just have a number that we we
will not go beyond
okay and in a perfect world
um everybody could join hands we would
all work together
and there would be no countries but
that's not the way it is
because the sociopaths power hungry
sociopaths
and [ __ ] religious
psychopaths okay if you could eliminate
those two people
those two groups of people
you know people who take the hocus pocus
[ __ ] too seriously
and then those those [ __ ]
those those people who will do anything
will [ __ ] do anything you know the
only feeling they feel is the rush
of putting their foot on somebody's neck
if you could just get rid of those two
people
i was kidding who we just look at us
look at us on the internet little wave
trash each other probably still wouldn't
work but whatever this is my utopia
i think we should have tapped out
somewhere around like um
i don't know when did the first atari
come out you gotta have video games
right
asteroids was great and you guys
whatever you get bored with it
but they come up with the new asteroids
maybe that maybe the
the ship would be shaped like a square
maybe the rocks were like hexagons no
rocks were hexagons
well you just make the the spaceship the
shape of the asteroids
and then the asteroids the shape of the
spaceship
new spaceship shaped asteroids and we
all would have been excited because we
didn't know any better because we didn't
know there was a bad
battlefield earth part four or whatever
the [ __ ] it's called whatever you video
guys
are doing there
i don't know what i'm saying so anyway
so bobby tells me to get this [ __ ] i
call up bobby kelly who
bobby is like you know when i go to bob
bob's apartment or whatever it's like
walking in my world it's like walking
like nine years into the future
you know remember when yankee stadium
first came out they were all arrogant
going we have
2013 technology in 2009
and when they said that [ __ ] which
really was the dumbest thing ever
it's like no if you had you have 2009
technology
that is not going to be available to a
nerd like me not a nerd a loser
like me until 2013. you're really just
sort of rubbing it in my face
all right of course all yankee fans say
oh they they got technology from the
future
derek cheater right
[Laughter]
oh it's your [ __ ] yankee jersey that
you can't button anymore
um anyways
what am i talking about here oh so bobby
yeah bobby's like nine years in the
future compared to me so
he he gets me this i get this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] wireless dude
everything bobby has has to be wireless
you know
he's [ __ ] wireless dude i i i i can
drive in a cab dude and i just think of
something it's it's
wired into my brain and the
um so i get this thing of course
this [ __ ] goddamn thing i've probably
used it 20 times
17 times i've had a [ __ ] problem with
it
one time for no reason i would i would
hit print
and it would go through the entire stack
of paper that i had
printing nothing just printing hell
happy
[Music]
and then finally the last two pages it
would just print a bunch of code
and you know i don't give a [ __ ] just at
some point in that five minute exercise
[ __ ] print when i'm trying to print
never does it
so then i gotta call bobby up bob this
[ __ ] princess did it doesn't suck
dude just
what's just tell me what go into
uh properties or whatever click on the
apple
gig and i'm on the phone for like 45
minutes
i like my old printer it had a wire
it was tethered to reality and i plugged
it into my [ __ ] laptop
you know i like that real [ __ ] and like
it's in the air man
i don't know what's going on i can't
figure that [ __ ] out
so anyways i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm even talking about here
what am i really saying why can't stuff
be easy why can't stuff what i really
want is for nothing to change so i don't
have to learn anything new i think
that's what i'm really trying to say
here
um i don't know i'm going to talk about
new york city here in a second once i uh
let's do a couple of uh advertisements
really quickly
if i can get oh jesus
oh jesus can you drink with joe derosa
tonight
oh no you know what i'm actually going
out to hasbro heights doing a benefit
um all right legalzoom everybody are you
waiting for the perfect time to start
your dream
business it's now legalzoom the official
sponsor of national start your business
month
wants you to get uh get your business
started right
whether you're setting up an ll llc an s
corp sole proprietorship or non-profit
legalzoom takes care of you from start
to finish
the award-winning service was developed
by the best legal minds in the country
and every business gets personalized
attention that's why over ninety percent
of legalzoom customers would recommend
this service to their family
you'll be in good company three dozen
companies in the inc
500 list were started through legalzoom
uh it's national start your business
month so start your business right now
at legalzoom.com
legalzoom is not a law firm and provides
self-help services at your specific
direction
in other words when you're having
problems get in touch with them
they got a legal staff that will help
you through it anyways but there's so
much more
now every llc and incorporation package
includes easy to use business accounting
software
a 269 dollar value for absolutely free
be sure to enter burr burr in the
referral box at the checkout
start your business protect your family
and safeguard your assets at
legalzoom.com today
all right back to the podcast um
so i'm back in new york city right now i
immediately went from um absolute
paradise as far as weather
goes you know not as far as population
and uh breathable air
drinkable water but uh the weather is
great and i i came here to new york
and uh you know i actually really
[ __ ] enjoy cold weather
and um the only thing that sucks was it
snowed like five days ago
so when it first snows it's it's
beautiful
it's like a newborn baby just gorgeous
everywhere you go looks like a postcard
but you know three four days later it's
just
uh you know you think you're you're in
eastern [ __ ] europe
and that's what it looks like right now
it's uh it's kind of a nice sunny day
but i gotta be honest with you um
if you're past the age of 40 and you're
still dealing with winters
i just want you to know that there are
options
you know what no no you know what keep
keep living in the last thing we need is
more [ __ ] people
in l.a it's great you know you get the
four seasons
you know one and a half of them are nice
[Laughter]
i like it you know i like to change your
seasons
do you have any idea what it's like to
just [ __ ]
just wake up every day and the weather's
awesome
it's awesome i know what east coast oh
dude you're going to lose your edge
that's how [ __ ] up east coast people
are we're afraid
that we're going to lose our anger
hey you're going to lose your edge but
be careful
you might end up being happy you might
end up
uh you know enjoying your life go
easy now i mean when i first moved out
to la the first time i was out there
when i hated it
and this didn't seem right and i fought
it so hard
to not to try and not enjoy it but i did
um i played uh roller hockey
on the day of the super bowl and shorts
and a t-shirt in this parking garage
um it's the 90s okay go [ __ ] yourself
and it was roller hockey
i wasn't skating down the board walking
a fanny pack but uh
if footage of me doing that does surface
um
i would love to say that it was somehow
photoshopped
for the record i never had a fanny pack
but not because um
i didn't like him i just found i just
i wanted pockets i just i don't like
[ __ ] on me
you know what i mean i just i don't like
it
then it makes your waist sweaty or that
wherever the fanny is
fanny pack is on the fanny pack that's
gonna get all sweaty
i don't [ __ ] like it you know
i just put the money in my sock and then
my keys and my other sock i used to be
that guy
you know anyways so i'm playing roller
hockey at the top of this [ __ ] uh
uh parking garage what the hell was it
was me
dane cook richter lee and pete coming
right
for two on two [ __ ] psycho game we
had
where it was like zero to zero and we
were all such competitive maniacs
this is back before tevo we almost
missed the beginning of the super bowl
because we had to play until somebody
won or maybe it was one to
you know when you don't have that
official clock or anything it was it was
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we were laughing just going like my
buddy was going who loved l.a i was like
dude we're gonna watch the super bowl
how nuts is this everybody back east is
freezing their [ __ ] balls off
we're out here in the sun playing roller
hockey on top of this parking structure
hoping the security doesn't come up here
and i was buying into that whole um
i'm losing my edge man i'm not going to
be funny
meanwhile la is one of the most
difficult cities i've ever had to live
in just as far as getting from point a
to point b
and also trying to keep your your head
screwed on
because um look it's a fun place when
you're working
that's all i can tell you when you're
not working uh if you are out there
right now and you're struggling uh
definitely
don't be afraid to have a hobby don't be
afraid to have something that you can
actually [ __ ] look forward to
that will actually help you you know
some of these psychos out there
24 7. i got to be about the business
hey you want to uh hey here's a free
cupcake would you like a cupcake i'd uh
work another script
you got to get the script on who turns
down a free cupcake
that's kind of weird one man to another
man huh
um anyway so i'm back here in new york
and uh
i don't know it's weird i love new york
but i just don't miss it i always
thought i would miss it but i don't miss
it i woke up you know
[ __ ] god knows what time this morning
it's a holiday back here you know it is
president's day or some [ __ ] and uh some
[ __ ] it's got his [ __ ] stereo on
like two floors down one of those douche
bags
um status is probably music is my life
music is the air i believe something
trite that they're trying to make
original or whatever the [ __ ] it is
um life equals music
he's [ __ ] playing his goddamn i i'm
going to say stereo because i don't know
what the kid's calling today
he's playing his [ __ ] stereo from two
floors down i'm hearing this guy at the
baseline of this ship
and you know i just don't miss it
like this is basically i live in a big
house with like you know
700 strangers i gotta smell their food
i gotta hear their arguments you know
you always got some sort of
there's always somebody there's always
some old person who's been living there
since like the [ __ ]
60s who's paying three dollars a month
in rent and you walk by their [ __ ]
place everybody's making some sort of
goulash
and the combination of that and the
[ __ ] heater that they can't adjust
for some reason and it's 9000 degrees
the combination of that and smelling
that goulash and that douche play in his
stereo i just i don't [ __ ] miss it
then i got to walk out look at dirty
snow i've had it
i was like oh yeah i remember this and
then there's that when it's getting
spring in new york was beautiful fall in
new york is great summer is cool for
about two seconds before the humidity
comes in
all the the [ __ ] crooked rich [ __ ]
slash celebrities
they all go out to the hamptons to go
[ __ ] air off their balls
and we got to sit here taking the
goddamn subway and all the office
it's the worst it's the [ __ ] worst
so um i think i'm just grumpy
i still like new york but i'm just kind
of disturbingly how much i'm sitting
here going like yeah this is
just really no way to live
you know what i i said this before new
york it's for young people you know
up to about 35 36 you can have a great
[ __ ] time those last four years is
just sliding into 40.
don't fight that feeling that says hey
why don't we get out of here and live
like a human being
you know [ __ ] the 212 area code you can
visit it
drop in and visit it go out to jersey go
to upstate new york whatever the [ __ ]
westchester get yourself a house in a
driveway
all right the only time you smell
goulash is if you're
as if you're making it you're a human
being you deserve to live like one
um anyways plowing ahead here
uh on the podcast what am i up to here
this is oddly cruising right along but i
can't find the numbers wherever
25 minutes is that roy
um i had a great week this week
this past week i got to do the conan
o'brien show we'll have the link for
that
up on uh up on the uh
monday morning podcast page um
conan's great you know when you're
getting going he chimes in and once you
get going he just lets you go he's
totally old school and if he thinks
you're funny he laughs
it's uh it really is that old school
johnny carson style and uh i'm getting
more and more comfortable doing those
panel things and i get a real kick out
of doing him because
that was sort of that was that's sort of
a lost art
amongst comedians just for the simple
fact that we haven't gotten the
opportunities to do it
where back in the day i guess there was
less opportunities maybe it balances out
but back in the day johnny carson
you know he had his go-to he would have
comics on and they
they weren't promoting anything he would
just have him on because they were they
were a great guest they'd come on and he
knew that they were going to hit a home
run
um and i used to grow up watching these
guys david brenner george global
all these guys and i would i would be
psyched when they were on and then come
on
buddy hack it they just come on and tell
stories
they weren't promoting anything they
were just hilarious and you'd watch
johnny laughing his ass off and it went
right through
letterman leno uh who are some of the
other guys i saw
but then i don't know once this talk
show stuff became so
well back then he was the only game in
town so there wasn't it's not
the way it is now where there's like 20
shows all trying to get this
take a piece of the same pie but anyways
um it was something i always wanted to
get good at so i was really psyched that
my
it went well uh
this past monday it's just something
that i i want to get better at
and uh i just i don't know that was just
like a cool thing that for a while
comics just really weren't getting that
opportunity or not enough of them
were getting that opportunity and it was
frustrating
i'm not saying all actors and all guests
but to sit there at home and
watch people coming out who couldn't
tell a [ __ ] story
but they had a giant movie which i
understand they got to promote the giant
movie
i don't know i just would always look at
that be like you know would be great
right now now that that person kind of
did
only okay and the host had to work their
ass off to help them through this
segment
if you just had a comma come on tell
some stories
and the host could take a little [ __ ]
breather
uh it's just great i don't know it's
just great that conan is doing that type
of thing
um and you know it's funny as a comic
you're always like man i want to do
those things those
five-minute sets it's like playing
russian roulette i'd rather just go out
and you just to watch somebody do panel
you think it's [ __ ] easy and then all
of a sudden you have to do panel you're
like oh my god what if i'm sitting there
bombing um i had a nice panic attack
before i went out there right before
i was standing behind the curtains just
like that why am i here
i have nothing to talk about blah blah
blah but uh
fortunately it worked out i did that and
then i
have an episode of that show the new
girl coming up i'll let you guys know i
finally decided i'm actually going to
tell you what i'm doing as opposed to
keep i think i've worn out that uh
glee joke at this point and i actually
got to work with
um nick kroll who i have to tell you
that guy
is one of the silliest funniest
[ __ ] i ever worked with
the whole cast was awesome and but nick
crowe
that dude is out of his [ __ ] mind and
um
i don't think i've laughed that hard you
know it's a one-camera shoot so
you're doing like 12-hour days and it's
like uh
you're like a zombie you know i actually
started like doing those things
i started to understand why my dog
sleeps all day
you know and it's basically because he
has nothing to [ __ ] do
she has nothing to do and if you have
nothing to do your brain's just like
okay we don't have to think we're just
gonna shut this down and you fall asleep
and that's what was happening to me i
was nodding off
because like when you're shooting it's
the most exciting [ __ ] thing ever and
you feel like you could run a marathon
then all right we're turning it around
or you're not in this next one
you just sit down
you have nothing to do everything else
is being handled
and you're just sitting there waiting
for them to tell you where to stand to
say the stuff that they wrote
right and in that time you just [ __ ]
you
nod off like a [ __ ] dog um
but anyways work i'm telling you man
check out the crow show i got it here i
want
i really want to hide this show because
i i think this guy is
i think he's absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant
um where the hell is it here come on
i'm the worst i think it's on wednesdays
what happened oh i know what happened i
had it up there and then my [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] recorded in work or
another
reality the recorder that works but i
can't figure out how it works hang on a
second
[Music]
close show you go comedycentral.com
the nick parole show is new episodes
wednesday at 10
30 9 30 central on uh
on comedy central he's absolutely
[ __ ] hilarious
uh and i really hope that show continues
to be a hit anyways
all right there's that there's the hype
for the week let's get back to uh the
podcast um
what the hell did i want to talk about
oh that meteor
how [ __ ] did you guys see some of the
footage people got
that thing just appearing out of the sky
now there's somebody somebody's going to
give me [ __ ] about technology there
but back in the day you had no idea it
was even coming
and you were just out there looked up a
diplo
doing whatever the [ __ ] you did back
then right and all of a sudden this
thing just comes out of the sky
i mean honestly if that thing falls in
your house you're dead but i was amazed
at the amount of people who are out
driving around
um if i was driving around i would have
looked like ray liotta in the second
half of goodfellas when he's all coked
up looking for that helicopter
that would have been me trying to get my
ass to a shelter um
is it is it agreed upon at this point
that that's how the dinosaurs
uh died off was that a giant meteor or
is that still just a theory
even though they probably found the
crater and proved it but the [ __ ] oh
people refuse to believe it because
somehow that [ __ ] with the adam and eve
story
how exactly has the church worked in
dinosaurs and all that
adam and eve they were together and they
were living in
uh paradise and uh
they started the human race forget about
the incestuous consequences of that math
we'll just say it was those two and they
were both white yet somehow
there's all these different races of
people uh
i don't know if that even makes sense
how did different races of people come
about
you know what's funny that's like that's
a great question to ask when you're in a
bar with someone with no scientific or
is it genetical is that the word maybe
just ask someone as dumb as me
people like oh you know this is [ __ ] i
heard in in bars like when i was growing
up that like
people in africa were uh
or africans i guess if that's an easier
way to say it
i went people in africa instead of
saying africans the same way everybody
who plays basketball now says the game
of basketball
rather than just saying basketball
you know when i'm out there playing the
game of basketball you know we started
that michael jordan
somebody said it to him and he liked it
as far as i can tell as far as my
by watching espn in the nba on
shibuya i think he was the first guy
he's the guy who made it cool to say
that the game of basketball
and these guys all grow up watching
michael jordan and they keep saying
hearing them say
the game of basketball now all these
[ __ ]
they keep saying the game of basketball
it's like this yoda ship
you know i mean i i really don't i can't
really
do a reference to yoda because i've only
seen that movie a couple of times but
i've seen a zillion comics do it where
you put the [ __ ] that usually comes last
first you know i don't [ __ ] know but
i'm really sick of hearing people talk
about the game of basketball
but i am loving lebron james saying that
he has the ability to become the best
ever
you know i am loving that he's saying
that it's just great to hear a guy
who's gonna try and go for that type of
thing and just the fact that he kind of
used to get a little tight at the end of
the game
these guys oh lebron's all grown up
you know and plus because i hate laker
fans and i hate kobe bryant i don't hate
him
personally but you know i just hate
oh by the way how's that whole uh magic
bryant [ __ ] working out for you
huh is he still passing the ball how
many times you [ __ ] laker fans gonna
fall for that [ __ ] he's turned over a
new leaf
he's actually gonna work with the rest
of the team you know
you guys keep coming back like a
battered [ __ ] wife oh maybe he won't
hit me this time
what quack um
anyways there's nothing more a celtic
fans enjoys more
than watching colby try and go for 60
points
keep shooting kobe three guys on you you
got it turn around jumper take it
get your 42 get your 42 points kobe
all day all day
um anyways
the [ __ ] am i going here ah
[ __ ] now i'm getting all [ __ ] freaked
out about this stupid thing did i put
did i put the wrong card in and then i
messed up did i is it if you put the
wrong card
in the thing does that does that mess up
the the brain on the thing
is that too technical a question hey you
know what's funny i i sent out a tweet
for uh
this guy and it's really only for guitar
players only
but um just how i i don't know the names
of [ __ ]
this guy is going off on people who
don't know the different names of the
like people but what do you have a maple
neck or a rosewood neck
and the guy's going you're dumb
[ __ ] it
everybody's got a maple neck
both these necks are maple the fretboard
fretboard is rosewood you got a rosewood
fretboard not a neck you're dumb
[ __ ]
he's just sitting here going off and he
ends with the greatest he goes you know
happy people
if you just played your guitar half as
much as you [ __ ] you might be worth a
[ __ ] on the guitar
i don't know it's tremendous so anyways
you probably like going hey bill
what are you doing what are you doing
back in uh
in new york city i am uh i am back here
put i'm doing a couple of benefits
tonight i'm at bananas and hasbro car
heights
uh doing a benefit for a buddy of mine's
wife
uh who is sick right now but is turning
the corner
and then tuesday night we we're gonna
have the
uh the big patrice o'neill benefit slash
send off
we're finally gonna send him off right
man like if this thing has been a long
time coming it's gonna be an insane
night
and uh i'm really psyched to see all the
guys who are going to be there
and uh it's definitely a good thing and
uh there you go
that's why i'm here and then i'm going
to go up to boston on wednesday going up
to the wilbur
i think of course the bruins are out of
town he played one time i couldn't watch
him because i'd be doing a [ __ ] show
but
um all right is it me or is it the
podcast kind of [ __ ] went downhill
hasn't it
it's kind of it's kind of dipped a
little let's let's get this back
let's get this back on track so [ __ ]
virzie knows that i'm going to be in
hashbrook heights tonight so you know
what he tells me he
he wants to go to white castle all right
and get a bunch of little white castle
burgers and a vanilla shake
because it's going to be epic now i'm
not going to lie to you i'm not going to
say that that isn't great but the fact
that versey
makes fun of new jersey you know
and that this and this you know going to
white castle and getting a vanilla shake
is his idea of a great night out
i mean paul verzi he's so
jersey his last name rhymes with it
you know he's talking about going to
this place like it's going to be a
steakhouse and this is the thing
i'm white trash too because i'm beyond
excited too i want to fire down
as many of those burgers as quickly as i
can the key is you got to eat them
really fast
before your body ruins the fun telling
you to please stop
doing it
[Laughter]
so if you're coming out to bananas
hasbro kites tonight
and about eight nine minutes into my set
despite the fact i'm leaning on the mic
stand but i'm inexplicably sweating it's
not because i'm nervous it's going to be
my body
trying to is beginning to eliminate
the 9 000 calories of uh trans fats i
just put in my body you know every once
in a while you got to keep your body
honest
you know i'm starting off great today i
had a banana for breakfast
i'm gonna have an apple as a snack and
i'm gonna have a giant [ __ ] salad
old twinkle toes here um for lunch
and then i'm throwing down that's how i
do it that's my balanced diet
all right i eat like i teach yoga for
the first half of the day
and john wayne from five o'clock on
[Music]
hey it's better than what i used to do i
used to start off you know bacon and
eggs and all that type of stuff
uh i know there's gonna be some people
out there going hey you know there's
nothing wrong with bacon and eggs i'm
not saying there
is all right but you know
listen for all you guys out there who
eat red meat and you want to see how
you know all the the the good things
about it and everything
look it i'm right there with you i love
eating a [ __ ] steak
okay i drive by a pasture and i have all
i can do to not get out of the car and
start
gnawing on some cow's neck all right
it's [ __ ] disgusting but it's true
um but look
[ __ ] all these diet books go out and eat
a giant goddamn salad don't drown in a
dressing
all right go with the balsamic
vinaigrette do that three days in a row
and you watch how well
your body uh operates
okay you will be a
finely tuned machine
and you can continue eating your [ __ ]
chops and all that crap
just eating one giant leafy green salad
a day
i'm telling you telling you and not only
that it kind of you know
quells that sugar salt [ __ ] arm
wrestle thing that you're doing the
whole day
it's really been helping me out and i
don't have to work out as much
and i think that that's uh that's really
the game plan isn't it
don't you want to be in shape and not
really have to work out
right did i just become some sort of i
should have a headset on right now and
like
doing that that little warm-up
side-to-side two-step that they do
okay everybody thanks for coming out
here we're gonna have a great workout
okay we're gonna
gonna start to put your arms out to the
side let's make little circles here we
go
now you know everybody i'm still doing a
little side to side i try to eat one
salad every day
i start breathing into that [ __ ]
janet jackson headset um all right
what do we got here we got one more
advertisement here oh the one you guys
are all waiting for stamps.com everybody
if you're sick of going to the post
office and you'd like to do everything
that you can do at the post office
within your own home
you need to be go be going to uh be
going to stamps.com
stamps.com you can buy and print
official us postage for any letter or
package using your own computer
a printer excuse me pick up stamps.com
will send you a digital scale
calculates the exact amount of posts
that you need for any class of mail
then you just hand your mail to the
mailman drop it in a mailbox or even
schedule a free package pick up using
stamps.com
you'll never have to deal with bad
weather again to send out letters and
packages
i use stamps.com to send all my dvds to
all my rogue gigs
it has worked i have never had a problem
right now use my last name burp burr for
this special offer no risk trial plus
bonus offer includes the digital scale
and up to 55 dollars of free
postage um don't wait
go to stance.com and uh click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bird burr that stance dot
com
enter burr all right okay saving your
time saving your time
um back to the uh
back to the pockets let's get to some
questions here shall we
shall we shall we do this uh all right
go [ __ ] up world
uncle billford i love how you guys every
week people you guys are coming up with
new different ways to say my name
william billford billy redface
billy fat face billy bag of donuts
um anyways when are we all when are we
all going to vote a joe
schmoe in as president just any other
guy than someone who's got this is like
classic ballroom talk
just any other any guy other than
someone who's got to pay back some
corporation or bank that got them there
in the first place
i understand you usually tackle
relationship advice
in a way this pertains to our
relationship with this with our country
no dude i would love to i would love to
answer conspiracy theory [ __ ]
the only reason why i you know what it
is is people listen every week
and they start i should start throwing
out more topics
dude conspiracy theory i'll always do
the relationship stuff
you want to talk sports anything you
want to talk about um
i will answer the questions and all you
guys have to realize is i am not a
[ __ ] expert and i do not know what
i'm talking about
all i'm trying to do is make you laugh
and make you drive to work a little
shorter that's all i'm doing here
all right anyways he says
in a way this pertains to our
relationship with our country every day
we hear our banks and governments
getting away with
crazy [ __ ] it's exhausting i want to
shut down
ignore and ignore it all but that's what
they want am i a stubborn
and i am a stubborn [ __ ] so [ __ ] them
what do we do
thanks frustrated son of a [ __ ]
um all right when are we gonna when are
we gonna vote a joe schmoen for
president that's never gonna happen
it's impossible to do we would all have
to get organized
and the organ organization to be able to
do that
um they would figure out that we were
doing it
then they would figure out who was
leading it and then that person would um
somehow get shot by a lone gunman a lone
crazed gunman a sirhan sirhan
and eddie eddie you know somebody with a
crazy [ __ ] name you know
um and let's just say
for the for the sake of argument that we
actually all got together secretively
and nobody found out we actually voted a
joe schmoen for president
uh nobody would work with him
no one would work with them and he and
it would be
in every politician's best interest to
have that guy have the worst presidency
ever
so they could all look at the american
people and be like see what happens
would you know vote democrat or
republican
they would just do that i mean they
don't even work with each other if a
republican gets
in as president and the house oh
i'm getting in over my head the house is
that what it's called
if that's democratic they won't work
with that guy they spend every waking
moment
trying to [ __ ] over whatever that guy's
trying to do
it's childish and vice versa spicy
person there
so they don't even work with each other
forget about some joe schmoe coming in
as president
i would say what you have to do is a
ground-up thing
i would try to vote for the most honest
person you could
as a local town selectmen as a regional
one of the then they have like sort of
regional senators and then state
senators and then like
senators at a federal level i don't
think i honestly don't think that there
is a way
uh you know what it'd be like
it's like you have a leaky faucet
and all you're trying to do is buy more
paper towels and keep wiping up the
water and you're never dealing with the
leaky faucet
okay the [ __ ] is
it's how do i how do i put this in my
own moronic way
all right i've done a lot of people's
shows
you know a little acting thing here or a
[ __ ] podcast here or a big time radio
shows
at this point i've done that stuff and
this is what i found
if the person at the top is a good [ __ ]
everybody
it everybody's a good [ __ ] everybody's a
good you know the person top is not an
ego maniac and not acting like an
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] diva everybody falls in line
because you can't act like an [ __ ]
it's like well this guy is making more
money than all of us and he's treating
people well
you know if i start acting like a dick
then it's just going to expose me as
being a dick
all right but if the person at the top
is a [ __ ] it it
you know and is just being an
unbelievable pain in the ass
you know it's that leadership thing it
just rolls downhill and everybody acts
that way
the problem with the world
is it's a [ __ ] or be [ __ ]
system that we have
all right and it's like it it starts
at the top with the [ __ ] over and they
pass that on to the next level and it's
hot potato you're trying
to pass the [ __ ] over on
you know what i mean and once you get in
the game you end up just
doing [ __ ] you don't even want to do you
just have to do it because that's how
the game's played
it's the whole bringing a knife to a
gunfight you can't do it it's a gunfight
you got to get it done and i don't know
i don't think i honestly don't think
the only way to change it is for
basically one of these asteroids has to
hit
the earth and we have to be wiped out
like the [ __ ] dinosaurs
and it has to start over again you know
because
we are flawed
that's like it's yeah we're flawed just
in general
even if you were able to eliminate
sociopaths just in general
we're jealous we're envious we're [ __ ]
and uh and we do not handle power wealth
generally speaking there's the
occasional [ __ ]
gandhi um uh a ralph nader
a jimmy carter now of course i gotta
name somebody on the right so people
don't get all [ __ ] there's like uh
it's just i don't i don't know enough
[ __ ] people
i'm just saying it's very rare okay
and you know what the [ __ ] is my phone
what the hell is it
i hear it buzzing can you hear it is it
on the floor
where is it am i gonna get mad at this
thing
oh there it is right there right in
front of me oh that's versi
bersie he's probably [ __ ] mouth
already watering
um yeah so you said
what do you do about it i would uh
i don't know i would just listen to
people and if they sound honest i would
vote for them that's basically all you
can do
short of starting a revolution at which
point you're gonna have to uh
you know be at the the
i don't know the forefront of uh a lot
of murder
[Laughter]
or you know you can just you know
find love and get to get yourself a dog
it uh you know tell some jokes i don't
know i i don't look
i try not to think about it it's it's um
i don't the way i look at it now is just
like good yeah when i see [ __ ] that's
right i mean this is
this is how i deal with the depression
of it as i just say oh good when i see
us doing something [ __ ] up good that's
oh that's great
you know there we go that will hasten
our demise
and maybe we can uh maybe something else
will come along
you know it was the dinosaurs were just
i don't know
i'm not going to say they were dumb but
they were kind of just taking up space
and then we came along you know the
asteroid alright you know
asteroid comes and whoever's running
[ __ ] whatever you believe is like all
right let's start over again
and it was just like an over correction
much in the way like feminism
was an overcorrection no it wasn't
feminism wasn't over correction what it
really was was a bunch of [ __ ] guys
who didn't who never said all right
all right that needed to be said
somewhere in the last 20 years there
should have been a giant all right
you know and i'll tell you right now
believe it or not that's what every
goddamn brought out their needs
especially the good looking ones
all right and if you're an honest woman
you know what i'm saying
you need a man in your life or if you're
gay you need a woman
in your life to be like all right
all right enough
which it would [ __ ] guys are the same
way we're like these big
[ __ ] kids and if we don't the same
way if you have a kid and i can speak
for this because i've never had one
if you have a [ __ ] kid and the kid
has no boundaries
he can be bouncing off the [ __ ] walls
acting like an [ __ ]
and guys like me are going to be looking
at a kid and actually having the
intrusive thought of what if i just gave
that toddler an uppercut
you know like that's how bad the kid's
behaving
like adults are the same way if we don't
have
any boundaries that's why so many of
these [ __ ]
these rich [ __ ] they got all the money
in the world they got everything they
need and they still [ __ ] their lives up
it's because because they
that nobody can keep them in check it's
kind of like when russia fell when
russia fell that was one of the worst
things that ever happened in this
country
russia kept us in check in that you know
we were sitting there grappling
you know we'd move three feet that way
they'd push us back four feet then we'd
move five feet we're just doing that
[ __ ]
then once they fell down and there was
that wide open space
yeah we did all the [ __ ] that we've been
doing
and uh you know
people are kind of looking at us like
we're a bunch of [ __ ] now aren't they
all right there you go they're
i tied uh asteroids dinosaurs
are in our foreign policy without ever
reading a goddamn thing about how'd you
like that everybody
i think i i hit new heights of ignorant
um
i'm too stupid even i don't know what
word comes next after that all right
what do we got here
all right what the [ __ ] is the next one
bill our family friend
our friend of the family an investment
banker from yale business school
extremely successful was married about
five years ago he was married to a [ __ ]
who went to harvard law school and
worked as a very successful lawyer
even when they were married okay so he's
an investment banker she
okay it sounds like an arranged marriage
this is one of those things where
every day somebody in their life has on
a blue blazer
anyways he says by themselves they made
more money in a year than most people
make in 10 years that's not their fault
they also studied hard enough to get
into yale and harvard or were born into
it
at which point good for them they got
lucky
um you know you can't get mad at people
who get who
who were born into going to yale and
harvard you can't get mad at that [ __ ]
unless
you're helping out people who are born
into sweatshop labor if you're actually
helping them get out of that then you
can get mad at that [ __ ] but if you're
just sitting in the middle
wearing sweatshop labor clothes and not
giving a [ __ ] and you weren't born into
sweatshop labor i don't think personally
i don't think you get mad at someone
who's born in that blue blood [ __ ] see
that
there's another [ __ ] bar room logic
for you there anyways by themselves they
made more money in a year than most
people make in 10 years when they got
divorced the husband got custody of the
kids but the wife got the house
and half of every penny the husband
would ever make
for the rest of his life
that doesn't make sense unless they came
drew that up
not only could she now easily support
herself she remarried another
lawyer that made just as much as her but
continues to spend the original
husband's money
but as far as i know when she gets
remarried the alimony stops as does the
child support i believe
unless he doesn't legally adopt them i
don't know it's weird and it also goes
from state to state and i've also never
read up on those laws people
just told me about them um anyways she
has no kids to take care of or anything
but she's still got everything we live
in massachusetts which means the divorce
laws heavily favor
females but still what the [ __ ] yeah uh
it's brutal
i think eventually they will be refor uh
reformed
uh reformed or reformed they will be
reformed in another shape they'll be
reformed
what i you know guys if you're still
listening to this [ __ ] podcast i mean
other than beyond to just listen how
[ __ ] stupid i am to make yourselves
feel better
please don't listen to me uh yeah dude i
mean they are what they are
the divorce lawyers are what they are
and um i'm done bitching about them
because i'm not doing anything i'm not
starting a movement to try and change
them
i'm a lazy [ __ ] i like to sit around and
complain
but um if you have a petition i'm all
about it i'll sign it
i'll definitely sign it in fairness
when the woman makes more money a guy
can do that to her too
uh but the way the world is set up the
guys make most of the [ __ ] money so
i guess that's one of the trade-offs so
in the words of mr hand get a good one
fast times richmond high reference to
you older people out there get a good
one
get yourself a good woman
um if i ever got divorced if i get
married and if i ever get divorced i'm
gonna tell you right now
i am gonna go into such a zen space
i already know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna get a one bedroom apartment
i'm gonna get an electronic drum kit
i'm gonna have one [ __ ] bowl one
plate one fork one spoon one knife
i'm gonna have a [ __ ] tv gonna have
all the sports packages
and i'm gonna dress like malcolm young
which is [ __ ]
jeans t-shirt no belt that's it
i'm gonna ride a bicycle and i'm just
gonna i'm just
i'm tapping out i'm never going to best
buy again i'm never going to target
other than after i get my ball can you
buy one ball i don't think you can
you know i'm gonna i will i will
i won't even have a vacuum cleaner i'll
have a little broom and a dustpan
and i'm gonna live like a [ __ ] monk
that's it and i'll give her all my
[ __ ] money i'll keep telling jokes i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll give her all the
[ __ ] money
hey you want it is this gonna make you
happy go ahead
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] it the [ __ ] do i care
know when it rains do i get wet no i
don't am i eating every day
fine i'm going to get into that mindset
and i'll send her that alimony and child
support check and i will
draw a big maniacal [ __ ] smiley face
on it
and uh that's it and i will show up you
know what i'm gonna buy i would i buy a
chevy citation
with the sideways radio and i would redo
that [ __ ] i'd have the ugliest [ __ ]
car
on top and underneath would be sweet
i teach myself how to do all of that
[ __ ] you know
that's what i would do that's what i
would i already have the game plan
you know this this is how you're
successful you gotta you gotta have
everything all mapped out
i'm not even married yet and i'm still
[ __ ] i already have a plan if i get
divorced
okay people you gotta think ahead
all right friends ugly chick uncle billy
boy if you're [ __ ] divorced right now
you want to do that rather than trying
to get all your [ __ ] back
how about this how about [ __ ] heaven
[ __ ]
huh there you go it's not the stupidest
thing you ever heard but think about it
there's a brilliance in there [ __ ] it
why do you need to have them you don't
need a man cave
you know then something's going to break
down and some
you know whatever the [ __ ] the geek
squad's got to come over there you don't
want to deal with that [ __ ]
how about keeping it simple have a
banana for breakfast
you know take some nhl games or some nba
whatever the [ __ ] you're into
sit there and read the paper you know
i think i'm onto something here
right [ __ ] ipods get a stereo listen to
a record
start cheering in butter just go go the
other way don't let her win
you go the other way start making your
own clothes
all right you don't gotta go that far
but you know what i'm saying um
anyways friends ugly chick take a pasta
making class
um friends ugly chick jesus this is
gonna be mean uncle billy boy
my friend recently got his uh into his
first
real relationship this [ __ ] broad is
a real [ __ ] to start
uh she doesn't want him hanging out with
any of his friends and basically doesn't
let him leave the house now i gotta tell
you something
that's complete [ __ ] okay it's
okay i agree with she doesn't want him
to hang out with any of his friends she
could be like controlling
and but to say she doesn't let him leave
the house is this guy literally trying
to leave the house
and she's [ __ ] putting him in a
headlock you know put him in a chicken
wing or some [ __ ]
figure four leg luck no your friend
is a [ __ ] with a capital p
dash [ __ ] this is
what no he's he he should be laying down
the law
he needs to be hey hey hey enough settle
down
settle down i'm with you
but i'm living a balanced life here let
me draw a circle here
this is the time of spending with you
this is the time i'm spending with my
friends this is my alone time
this is my drinking bear time all right
the whole circle has to be filled with
different [ __ ] sweetheart
or i'm not gonna be happy are you
telling me you want me to be
miserable if you are i am leaving for
good if you're not then [ __ ] work
with me
all right that's what your friend needs
to say before i even get through all
this anyways he goes
living in buff the buffalo it is rather
customary to go out once a week for
chicken wings beer
and watch some good guts watching some
goddamn hockey oh by the way
shout out to the sabers they [ __ ] own
the bruins
it is just a regular season i'm not
trying to jinx you guys but you guys uh
you're kicking our asses i know what
sucks is i taped the last game
i'm not trying to avoid an ass kicking
but you know for some reason i taped it
i came home and the screen was blank i
think it was actually on the nhl network
i take the wrong um i taped the wrong
one so i actually missed it um
i did read the box scores and all that
type of stuff uh
you know i love how you guys keep i keep
forgetting the guy's name
your big six foot eight inch goon how
you guys keep giving
bruins fans [ __ ] that milan lucich won't
fight
was it john scott whatever his [ __ ]
name why would
why the [ __ ] would you do that
hey let's have one of our best players
one of the best power forwards
in the league fight a guy
six foot taller than him who weighs 50
more pounds than he does
six inches taller than him whatever six
inches taller outweighs him by 40 50
pounds and who's an absolute
goon there's a great trade-off and then
we'll have lucich
who can score goals and actually play
the game sit down for five minutes and
all you guys do is lose a goon
why would we do that and we're risking
having one of our best players get hurt
why would we do that that was like back
in the day when montreal canadian fans
would get pissed that that he wouldn't
fight george larocque
you know because he beat up one of their
[ __ ] uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] he beat up
some guy
hey i don't know someone who's going uh
lou cheech never fights anybody his size
i i click up blue cheech fight
uh on youtube i search him the first guy
he's fighting is a guy his size who
actually weighs more than 15 pounds
than him again some guy in toronto and
he beats the [ __ ] out of him
okay who cheats could be your guy up
your [ __ ] family up and uh and
something else to make three all right
stop questioning his toughness you can
do it all you want but i'm not buying
into it
hey how come your best guy isn't
fighting the guy that we have that can't
even play
um anyways let's let's continue on here
and by the way you gotta go to buffalo
[ __ ] niagara falls
you got to go to uh was it duffy's or
anchor bar i never i went to anchor bar
like the one time in history they ran
out of wings
i was with jersey again we went to
anchor bar first
the first night and then the second day
we were going to a sabres game we went
to anchor bar
uh and they they ran out of [ __ ]
wings
so um and i gotta tell you man they make
them like nobody else in the goddamn
country
um so anyways he goes this broad won't
even let him out of the house
i won't even let him out once a week for
that
she has wrapped his brain so badly
warped his brain so badly that he now
thinks she's
right in saying we are a bad influence
on him
we've all been friends since early
elementary school for christ's sake
and she's only known him a couple of
months
here's where it gets [ __ ] up he's by
no means a bad looking guy
and she looks like she got bumbushed
and was beaten in the face with the club
and for the cherry on top
on top she has herpes now how do you
know that
unless that guy got out and told you
bill what the [ __ ] do i do to wake him
up
um there's nothing you can do
[Applause]
there's nothing you can do come on man
this that like that guy
is either wired to be submissive
or he wasn't raised right you know
i think a big thing you know with the
kid that i don't have the way i try to
raise my kid that i don't have
is i just realized i've been leaning
back and sitting forward so i'm sure the
volume is all over the place i apologize
uh one of the biggest things you got to
do with kids is you got to get them
out of this shell you know what i mean
um like i had uh you know
uh who the hell was
who was it one of my friends i'm trying
to do is that i don't like talking about
people in my life
whatever somebody i knew came down they
were only in
in their uh i guess right around the
high school age and they came down
to new york and i immediately first
thing i did i made made them like hail a
cab
walk into a bodega i'd show them how to
work if you [ __ ] get a paper you
don't have to stand in line just put a
quarter down and just hold it up and say
post or whatever daily news
you know just and got him immediately
acclimated
into speaking up and interacting with
the [ __ ] city
and the person within like you know
two days had that [ __ ] down
and was like oh man i feel like a new
yorker and like that that's what you
have to do with kids you got to get them
um you can't have those kids that hide
behind your [ __ ] leg when when um
that you know you're meeting someone
this is mr so-and-so and they're hiding
behind your leg you can't have that you
got it from [ __ ] day one get them out
there
shake hands look people in the eye
talk and you i don't know how to do it
so i never had a kid but i think it's
really important to have
to get your kid in tune with what
he or she is thinking and what he or she
wants nobody wants that situation
um and if this woman is the way you're
painting her out to be
this is the only type of person because
she's so [ __ ] insecure
that she can actually be with does she
have to find somebody so
weak that um
that person can allow them to just
completely take over their lives and
i'll tell you what's funny is after a
while
these controlling type of [ __ ] people
they end up hating the person
that they're with they do because they
just don't respect them after a while
you know what i mean they finally got
exactly what they wanted this person
that they can use like a [ __ ] robot
and then in the end they don't respect
them so um
i don't know what i would um you know
what dude this is a childhood friend i
could tell you really wanted the guy
back he
take a shot taking it back
um don't say that she's ugly
don't mention her herpes it's just be
like i mean dude i i
you're literally trying to undo this
guy's hard drive at this point
if this guy's self-esteem is just
[ __ ] low this is you know
this is like why the doctor phil show
sucks is because somebody's going to
come in here and
this is like you talking about this guy
i'm guessing is at least in 25 years old
you're talking about a quarter of a
century of thinking one way
and then you watch dr philly be like you
gotta stick up for yourself
do you want to go out with your friends
you got a tailor
all right we're going to commercial and
like it doesn't work like that and also
on dr phil show he would never do that
because he would actually be supporting
the [ __ ] guy
okay at the end of the day it's a
goddamn business and who watches that
show but a bunch of broads
um yet you somehow know something about
it don't you bill
well i i live with a woman she doesn't
watch them anymore
i just can't make fun of making kept
making fun of how dr phil looks like a
crooked cop
um i don't know he just that guy does
not look trustworthy to me at all
i i mean you know i'm just judging him
you know the same way people judge me
it's all fair it's all fair in love and
war all right that's the podcast for
this week everybody
uh i'm actually going to go to a sports
bar here and watch the islanders i'm
becoming a [ __ ] islanders fan
i've been watching them lately they're
turning the corner i hated them when
they were a kid just because they were
awesome and
every time the bruins would get the one
time
and we never got past the canadians back
in the day that uh if we somehow lucked
out and somebody else beat the canadians
this is pre 1988 we basically owned
the [ __ ] canadians since
i hope you guys really realize that
montreal you guys have not been a
[ __ ]
factor in our lives since 1988
it's been great it's been a wonderful 25
years i know what you guys are saying oh
we beat you in this playoff series
beating that playoff series hey that
shit's gonna happen
we used to never beat you all right
good luck with your rebuilding i'm just
[ __ ] with you actually like what you
guys are doing up there
um okay what am i talking about here
that's the podcast for this week
uh anything i have to announce
i'm at the wilbur theater this weekend
thank you everybody for buying the
tickets i'm going to try to give you a
heck of a show
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
and if you're in a relationship like
that
uh last guy you need to get out of it
you should be allowed to have friends
and go out and see the meteors crashing
into earth all right
see you next week am
on my own
[Music]
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
the world still spins around
without you no one
but to